Well from the happy Hubba by gather,
you're as eager as I am to get this over.
So the last lecture is,
is a review of what we've done before actually,
but it's focused on synthetic chemistry.
In particular,
the sentence,
the synthesis of Cortisone,
which is a natural product.
Cortisone looks like this.
It's one of these steroids which you remember have three six membered rings than
a five membered ring and various alcohols and ketones and so on.
And in fact,
the,
this,
this lecture originated with a book,
uh,
called advanced organic chemistry,
although I've used it so much that you can't tell it from the spine anymore.
Uh,
that was written in 1961 when I was taking organic chemistry by Louie feezer at
Harvard,
who was the person I had had a f I was having at that time for this course.
Uh,
he was,
uh,
very good,
a synthetic organic chemist and he worked a lot on steroids.
In fact,
in 1936 he wrote this book,
which is called chemistry of natural products related to finance three.
Finance three is a thing like three benzene rings,
bing,
bing.
So you see steroids are related to finance three.
And so that's what this book was about.
He also was,
he was a stylish guy,
uh,
before I got there.
It was reported that he walked around with a gold headed cane.
He had dropped that affectation by the time I arrived,
but he still smoked like a chimney,
although at that time he was on the surgeon general's committee about smoking
and health and he absolutely quit then and went on.
But he ultimately succumbed to lung cancer.
So a,
this is a way a homage to him.
Uh,
these are some of the,
uh,
steroids,
the ones that are a sex hormones.
So very small amounts of them go around and make various things happen in your
body.
And they began up at the top left with cholesterol and you can see how various
enzymes oxidize it.
Put a ketone here and alcohol here,
make an unsaturation and so on to make all these important,
uh,
compounds.
In fact,
they were recognized as so important that work on steroids awarded four Nobel
prizes between 1927 and 1950.
Right?
And another three between 1965 and 1975 which was at least part due to,
to work on steroids,
right?
The awards in 1927 and 28.
We're determining the structure and the one in 1965 recognize the synthesis of
it.
You have to know the structure before you can synthesize it.
Obviously.
In fact,
the ones at 19 and 27 and 28 were for determining the wrong structure.
The thing that got the Nobel prize for it was this structure,
which doesn't have three,
six membered rings,
big,
big like that.
But it got settled in the 1930s.
Okay.
So by 1950,
the Nobel prize in physiology or medicine was awarded to Kendall Rice Stein and
show Walter for their discoveries relating to the hormones of the Adrenal
Cortex,
their structure and biological effects.
So Kendall and Rice Stein where organic chemist and show Walter was a
physiologist,
uh,
and uh,
hunches.
Nobel address said the air of pessimism regarding rheumatic disease in general
and rheumatoid arthritis in particular still finds expression in some of the
modern writings and text.
But then he goes on to describe how he had a patient at the Mayo Clinic,
uh,
who,
65 year old patient who an unusual story a few days before he came.
He was painfully affected with rheumatoid arthritis.
It had been for four years,
then jaundice suddenly developed and within a week,
most of his arthritis,
meth manifestations had disappeared.
The jaundice last five weeks and the rheumatic arthritis did not relapse until
several weeks after the jaundice had disappeared.
The thought occurred,
instead of being relentlessly progressive,
this disease,
rheumatoid arthritis may be potentially reversible more so than we'd believe,
perhaps rapidly.
So,
so during the next five years,
from 29 to 34,
while the organic chemists,
we're determining the true structure,
observations were made on 16 patients with chronic arthritis or fibrositis in
whom jaundice of different types and degrees developed.
If the jaundice was deep enough and was characterized by bill,
a rube anemia of the direct reacting type,
the rheumatic symptoms quickly diminished or disappeared for varying lengths of
time and then gradually returned.
And furthermore,
it was noted that during pregnancy people lost that.
So there was something that was thought to be some hormone that would do this.
Uh,
so,
uh,
they figured that out.
You can read that yourself.
Okay.
Uh,
so they took rice die and then the,
the,
the uh,
Swiss chemist took a thousand kilograms of the adrenal glands from cattle,
uh,
and was able to get at one kilogram of dry residue from that and follow the
activity is the partial parceled out in clean,
including using Gerard's ketone reagent t remember we talked about,
that's a thing that makes a hydra zone and that it has a permanent cad,
ionic charge.
So it'll take a ketone into water,
then you can take it off and it'll go back into the organics.
That was a powerful way of separating these ketones.
And um,
so there we go.
So they got seven,
eight grams of a ketone out of that.
So this was this fish up to extract ketones and we've talked about that before.
So I'm just going to click through it very rapidly to show how it was
synthesized and how we know what it did.
Okay.
Only when pure crystal and homogeneous substances were produced,
where they tested as far as possible biologically.
So accurate determination that chemical structure was given priority in nearly
all cases that could,
this could be elucidated in all its details.
So now by 19,
by the mid 1930s,
they had what the structures were and here were,
uh,
some of these steroids from the Adrenal Cortex,
29 of them,
of which these five,
uh,
were particularly important as active.
Right now,
those two you notice are on the top cortisol.
It has an Ooh group in that top left here and below it is cortisone,
right?
The ketone.
Okay.
Uh,
so though that position 11 and the position 17,
where were particularly important,
then you have to have that ketone at 11 to get a cortisone.
The introduction of an oxygen atom and position a 11 of the steroid skeleton is
one of the major difficulties in this synthetic production of cortisone.
Why?
Because it's so far away from any other functional groups.
It's not alpha to something or on the Beta position where an Alphabait
unsaturation could be used.
Right.
The preparation of this subject,
the substance from dysoxia cholic acid still remains a long and laborious way,
even when so many improvements to it had been discovered.
If it is wished to obtain cortisone more simply,
there remain two ways,
either total synthesis or the discovery of a better qualified raw material
that's close in structure to this that then you can convert into this for
medical purposes.
Both will be tried.
The prospects of a total synthesis are difficult to access to access.
Okay,
so it's going to be tough to do this either total synthesis or got find a better
raw material.
And there's a footnote.
There are be Woodward referred to the partial synthesis of an acid,
which is already very closely related to cortisone nine April,
1951 in Boston mass.
And it gives a reference here.
Okay,
so,
uh,
this,
this book that I talked about uses as an example of a total synthesis Woodward's
synthesis in 1951 of cortisone.
And this is it,
but we're going to go through it slowly.
So this is the thing he wanted to make,
right?
It's got these four rings,
a,
B,
c,
and d,
and obviously it's going to take a lot of steps to get there.
And you'll,
uh,
so the first goal is to make rings C and,
d.
Why did I put a question mark on d?
It's a six membered ring,
not a five membered rings.
So he's got something clever in the back of his mind when he thinks of that as
the first thing he wants to make.
And that will be a handle that double bond on the far right.
A handle to allow modification to make the ring a smaller size and put the
functionality that you need on there.
Okay.
And,
and this double bond at the top left of ring c is a thing that's going to allow
us to get access to put the ketone on there.
Okay.
And down at the bottom,
this ketone is a handle.
It's at this position down here,
here,
this is going to be handled to build the ring's a and B.
So we'll see how that works.
So this compound was known and ready,
readily available and cheap,
so you could get a lot of it to start with.
Okay.
So the first reaction he did was to build ring d onto that.
How did they do that?
What kind of reaction could build ring d make these bonds that are highlighted
in blue here?
Anybody got an idea?
Yeah,
it deals all the deals.
All the reaction.
Right?
Okay.
So he did that and do this standard old deals,
all the reaction that you put that ring on.
But notice that's going to,
when you put those,
when,
when the dying sits down on top of that double bond,
the methyl and the hydrogen are going to be on the same side.
Right?
Whereas over here,
they want to be on opposite sides.
Right.
So we better get that fixed up so that they won't have the wrong stereo isomer.
When we get to the end.
Can you see any way to change it so that this hydrogen is no longer a pointing
down but pointing up?
Yeah.
What's,
yeah,
Amy.
Yeah.
Ah,
Mitsa Nobu in births and alcohol.
If you have an alcohol,
you can go from right handed to lefthanded.
Right?
But this is no alcohol here.
What functionality is handy role?
Okay,
what's special about the position of that age?
Pardon?
We want to pull that hydrogen off and put it back on on the other side.
Is there any way they're resilient hydrogens in here?
Ayesha?
Ah,
Ian Olina late.
All right.
Okay.
So,
uh,
so we wanted to go to that and you do it with base.
It's an needle late and this and the Trans isomer is more stable so it goes all
over there.
Okay,
bye.
The EDA late.
And now we're going to make the ketones into alcohols.
Can you think of a reagent that could do that?
This is review.
What kind of reagent is necessary?
A reducing agent.
Something that'll add hydride to the carbon eel.
Any ideas?
Pardon me?
Hydrogen Peroxide.
Good idea everyone.
Why?
It's an oxidizing agent,
not a reducing agent.
Okay.
Lithium aluminum hydride does the trick.
Okay,
so you'll do that.
Now what they want to do is get from this dial now over here to a ketone in an
unsaturation.
You already have an unsaturation here.
Okay.
So,
uh,
let's think about how we do that.
We could,
the oxidation levels turn out to be the same,
right?
So you just use acid to eliminate at la,
I sit in water so you can protonate and get that cat eye in,
right?
But why get that cat eye on?
Why not protonate here and get the cat eye on the bottom are protonate here and
lose methanol and get the cat eye on there.
Well,
the cat eye and here is no good because it's a sigma,
it's in the sigma system.
It's not conjugated with the double bond.
This one is Al Alec.
But that one would be at Lilly too.
Right?
But if you make that one,
then the resonance structure is here.
There's Pas,
there's the vacant orbital,
the low Lumo is here and here,
right?
And it's adjacent to the unshared pair on oxygen.
So that's the one you want to do.
So it takes off the one they want to take off at the top.
You get that right?
Okay.
Now you do an Allen Lilly rearrangement of,
of Ooh,
right.
So are you complete the Alec Arrange Rearrangement?
You took it off here and you put it on here.
Now what functional group do you have now?
Yeah,
when you have O,
h n o r on the same carbon,
Roy,
he tau.
What does it do when you,
what does the heavy key towel do?
Loses alcohol.
Right?
So the heavy asset towel here,
treat it with acid.
Protonate lose that.
And you've got the ketone now,
right?
So we,
we've got it to here,
but we need to get this,
Ooh,
off to get down to what?
He wants to build this over here.
So he treats it with a Siddique and hydride,
right?
What does an alcohol do with a CD?
Can Hydride the Oh,
a tax.
The Carbon Eel acetate leaves.
It's a substitution reaction that an ACL carbon,
right?
So you've put acetate on here.
Okay.
And now to get from here to here,
we have to change and Oh,
on the ring into an h on the ring.
What kind of reagent do we need
change?
We need a reducing agent,
right?
So like a metal.
So we use the zinc.
So zinc comes in,
gives the electrons the acetate leaves,
right?
So we generate this and I and then that double bond and ina late.
But of course this is a resonance structure of it.
And you put a proton on the ad.
I end down there.
So he's got to that.
So now we're ready for the next step and the next step is to build,
ring be all right.
And also to protect the double bond here so we'll won't react when another
double bonds react.
Okay?
And this thing here on B building,
this thing on B will be a handle to construct ring a.
Okay.
And that double bond here gives you access to that place,
which is,
remember where we need to put a ketone,
which is sort of off in left field.
Okay.
So the first thing is to re build,
ring be.
Did you ever see a thing like that where from a,
from a ketone.
Here we build a whole six membered ring down here.
We saw it two lectures ago.
Yeah,
the Robinson annulation.
Okay.
So what we need is ethyl vinyl Quito,
not methyl vinyl ketone,
but Ethel,
in order to get this extra methyl group in here.
So this thing,
which normally would be methyl vinyl ketone is now ethyl vinyl ketone.
So we'll have that methyl group on there.
Okay?
So Ethyl Vinyl Ketone,
right?
Generate the eternal eight,
uh,
does a conjugate edition or sometimes called a Michael Edition,
right?
Make that [inaudible] an ion protonated and now make the other Ian laid and iron
and have it attack the carbon eel to make the beginning of that double bond.
What would you call that kind of reaction if you make this analyte react with
this and end up with an Alpha Beta unsaturated ketone.
So you have a ketone attack.
Another key tone to give an Alpha Beta unsaturated Quito.
Remember what you call that?
Aldol you still have a week?
Don't panic.
Okay.
So we're going to do an aldol reaction and then,
and then,
and then get over here.
Okay?
Now what we do there in order to make this protected group is treat with Osmium
tetroxide.
We know that that makes a dial.
We talked about that when we were talking about a para cyclic reactions.
Okay?
So you can get the dye all,
then you make the dial into this carbon with two more methyls on it.
What kind of,
what kind of functional group is this?
Yeah,
two.
Oh,
ours on the same carbon.
That's a full asset towel,
right?
And you make it by reacting or Ketone ketone acetone with the dial.
Okay?
That,
so we're going to get this key towel or acid towel.
Okay?
Now we need to go across from here to here,
right?
And what we're doing is removing this double bond,
okay?
So that's done with catalytic hydrogenation,
right?
And notice that's why we had to protect this double bond here because it would
have been destroyed.
And if it was destroyed,
then you'd have no functionality out here.
In order to change the six ring into five membered ring and put the other stuff
on.
So you had the,
you had to first protect this,
then get rid of this one.
Okay?
So now he's got this compound
and now he's going to work on ring D or department.
He's going to,
we're going to knock ring d off while we work on ring so the whole slide won't
fill up.
Okay.
So we'll just take that big thing up there and work on ring a now,
what kind of reaction by make ring a,
an Alpha Beta unsaturated ketone here?
Yeah.
Any reactions that you have?
Alphabait unsaturated ketones.
Aldol reaction.
So that's what we're going to be looking for,
but there's some problems as you'll see.
So we're going to do that.
We're going to get this and then an algal reaction on that.
We'll make this and we can get this by adding the anti and here conjugate to an
Alpha Beta unsaturated ketone here.
What do we call it?
Okay.
What do you call that kind of reaction?
The whole thing.
Te Te to start from here and build this ring.
Build ring.
You said it before,
Rob Robinson.
Annulation we're going to do it again.
Okay.
So that would be ready for the ALDOL.
And now this double bond here is even closer to where we needed in order to make
that ketone.
Okay.
Now how do you do that?
Now there's a problem,
you'd have to make the eternal light to do the Robinson animation,
but this is where you formed the eternal light down there.
Not this,
you could remove one of these hydrogens would make an ina late,
or you could remove,
remove one of those hydrogens and make an anti in there,
which would be Allah Lake with it.
I had an eye on there,
which is an Ino eight,
right?
So this one is called a vanilla Gus analyte.
It's got an extra double bond in between,
but still it,
it would behave as an Adelaide.
But the problem is that this one is more reactive.
You want to make the analyte here,
which you can do by removing one of those purple ages,
right?
And then having their anti and be there as a resonance structure.
That's fine except that these are the ones that get pulled off easier.
So what do you do?
You go ahead and pull these off,
tie 'em up somehow with something else,
then get the other one and then come back and take off what you had put on their
use of protecting group.
Okay.
And notice incidentally that there's another age here that could also be pulled
off that would have a resonance structure was the anti in here.
So there are lots of possibilities.
Okay.
You want to get that and I,
which is like that and I n okay,
so,
so first you have to protect the more reactive Alpha position and they do that
by that.
That's just abbreviating what's above make the eternal eight attack.
That carbon eel,
which has a leaving group on it.
Yeah.
So the och three,
we'll leave and generate this dykey tone.
Right.
That's like a climax and reaction that we talked about last,
last time were at,
at ELA to tax an Ester and the,
and the alcohol leaves.
Right.
And then that gets attacked by an amine to give this
and that dehydrates,
it's like making an alphabet unsaturated ketone,
except it has this nitrogen on it now,
which helps out.
The unshared pair on the nitrogen is stabilized by this.
You can draw a resonance structures that put charge on the oxygen.
Okay.
So this is like an alto and Alpha Beta unsaturated ketone also noticed it's an
intimate,
okay.
So that's tied up the downstairs part and now you can proceed with making the
anti a new one,
right,
which is going to add to there and hopefully by a Robinson methyl vinyl ketone
or pardon me,
it would be a,
yeah,
methyl vinyl,
Quito.
And this time,
because the first time we had to put the ch three in there,
where do we use that [inaudible] apartment?
Me when we use this ina laid over here.
Now,
now we don't need a ch three,
uh,
here,
here.
So we don't need it.
We can use methyl,
except it doesn't work.
The reaction doesn't work.
So you have to do something a little more around about,
okay.
So that doesn't work,
but you can,
uh,
you can add,
add it to,
if you can't add it to methyl vinyl ketone,
you can add it to the double bond here.
Do a conjugate addition to this sort of like a ketone to that night trial.
Okay.
So the [inaudible] adds to this carbon,
generate the anti and next to the night trial done protonated and you've got
that conjugate addition again.
Okay.
Uh,
now,
uh,
but the,
the,
this,
the problem is there's a ca the ch three here could be either up or down,
right?
You could have added to either face of that an island.
Right?
So here's what,
here's what they said in the paper about that the protected ketone was condensed
with a Carrillo night trial.
That's that compound with Cy.
And I end up at the top in the presence of aqueous Triton on B and t,
butanol,
benzene,
Eh,
try Triton be
in,
I'm not sure what the end is any in TV.
Oh,
in it,
the eyes left out in t butanol,
benzene,
solvent,
and the product on basic hydrolysis yielded this long name thing as a mixture of
two isomers.
That's the problem.
That's a mixture of two isomers.
And that's just lore,
whether you're going to get something like that and it,
sometimes you just have to suck it up.
That's not a,
because there's no hydrogen you can pull off here,
right.
To make it come on the other side.
That's just the way it is.
So you've got to throw away a certain amount of your stuff.
Okay.
So that's tough,
right?
So then they used a,
uh,
strong base and water,
which removed this protecting group,
right?
Made it back into the,
uh,
to the ch two here,
okay.
And at the same time,
it was strong enough that it hydrolyzed the night trial to make a carboxylic
acid there.
So now treat that with acid protonate there.
Then protonate here,
making that cat ion,
but that can attack the carbon eel to get that,
which can then lose a proton.
So you've got a six membered ring.
So we made it
not quite,
we got the wrong element there.
Oxygen instead of carbon at the bottom,
right?
So we need another carbon in the system,
So protonate their cad ion eliminate,
we got that double bond,
okay.
But now we need to convert that into ring a,
we need to put that extra blue methyl group on there.
Okay?
So the way to do it is that use methyl grin yard.
So the methyl minus adds to the Carbon Eel,
and that is alleving group.
Okay.
And that's an analyte.
So it becomes a ketone.
And we've got this thing here,
okay.
So we're getting close.
It's closer now.
Okay.
You do an alcohol and you have ring A.
So this is a typical thing that happens.
It looked like a Robinson had Alation might go directly there,
but it didn't work.
So they do a work around,
okay,
so now a is all set and now we need to work on ring d,
which is,
remember a six membered ring and it needs to be a five membered ring.
Okay?
So we'll put it up in the corner and start working on that.
Okay.
So the first thing that that,
what they're going to go for is to make it a five membered ring that has an
ester group coming off.
So you have that carbon group that we're gonna want.
Okay.
So the first thing they do is treat it with acid and water.
What do they do that for?
Yeah.
What's that going to do with that compound?
Ayesha?
Right now you get rid of the protecting group.
You want to be able to work on that double bond now.
So you'd take the protecting group off that you had on there when you were doing
a catalytic hydrogenation.
Okay,
so now,
um,
now that we've got the dial and now treat it with a per ionic acid,
do you remember what that does?
Is it oxidizes a dial to cleave the carbon carbon bond in between,
right?
And make two carbonyl groups.
Okay?
So at first did a ads and then it,
that's just an intermediate transient intermediate comes apart to give to
aldehydes.
And now how are you going to get a five membered ring?
All
right?
You could make an eternal eight here,
attack that carbon eel
or make an needle eight here,
attack this carbon eel.
Those are going to give different products,
right?
What you would need to do is to have,
is to have this analyte attack,
this carbon eel.
If you want to make that compound rather than have the,
have this,
uh,
this thing form,
react with,
with that one,
have,
have this,
eat a light,
react with that one and get the carboxylic acid down here.
Okay?
It turns out that base with Al Doll,
uh,
could be either that way or that way.
And luck made it go the right way this time.
Robinson and Alation didn't work before,
but this one worked the right way.
Okay.
And then we've got an Aldehyde.
We need the carboxylic acid.
So he used a dichromate oxidation,
which we talked about the oxidize and alcohol.
And of course you don't stop at the Aldehyde,
you go onto the acid,
but you need the Ester.
So now they're going to make the ester.
You could do Fischer esterification,
but that's an equilibrium.
And this stuff is becoming very precious because all the work that you've put
into it.
So you want to do this in the highest possible yield.
So they use dyes or methane,
remember,
which is the way of doing it.
It really take to change the acid and methanol into methyl ester and really high
yield.
Okay?
So that's a dangerous compound to work with.
It's,
it's much as much more expensive and cumbersome than doing a methyl,
uh,
Fischer esterification,
but it gives a really high yield.
So that's what they did.
Okay.
Uh,
so now,
uh,
they had this cop,
they had the ketone here and now they made it into an alcohol.
Now this looks nuts,
right?
They already had the Quito in there,
which is what they want,
right?
And the double bond here,
They've got it.
Why do they backtrack?
They backtracked because it was already known from 1918.
Well,
uh,
so they used the borrow hydride this time to reduce the,
to reduce the ketone do an alcohol without,
if they'd lift used lithium aluminum hydride it would have reduced the Esther to
an alcohol.
They didn't want to do that.
Right?
So you have to choose the reagents carefully when there's possible competition
like that.
Now it was 19 nine,
it was found out that this alcohol could be separated.
The two e Nao Timmers easily.
That was already known like 50 years before.
Right?
So,
so they in order see all this stuff they'd been doing started with,
with a chiral material.
So they've got both right and left handed stuff there,
and they want only the one,
the one iga antibody.
Ultimately they've someplace they're going to have to separate it.
And this is where they do the separation because it turns out if you put this in
together with this digit tonin stuff,
which itself notice has a six,
six,
five steroid inside,
it does complicated serpiginous as it's called.
Uh,
then those things come together.
and what precipitates is just one hand.
The other one stays in solution,
right?
So this was obviously [inaudible],
but anyhow,
they got that.
And now having made this,
it turned out that previous studies of cortisone had shown that if you had this,
you could make this from it,
right?
So this in this is called a total synthesis,
but in fact it's a formal total synthesis or a relay synthesis.
Because by the time they got here,
they had very little material.
So they couldn't do a bunch more steps.
But it was known that those steps could be done because people had already done
them.
Right?
So they could then start with material which had been made from cortisone or
some other sterile and then carry it through.
But there was no point in doing it because people had already done those
reactions.
And this is,
so this is the paper,
this is the whole paper that described the total synthesis of cortisone.
Woodward was not a man of many words,
right?
There actually had been a previous paper of about two pages about about making
the precursor that we showed,
right?
So,
so he then had this,
he did a,
he reduced this double bond,
right?
But notice it didn't reduce this what?
It didn't reduce.
Pardon me?
It did reduce this one and this one but didn't reduce this one.
So again,
this is testing the various methods you're using to make sure what's,
what's going to react and what isn't.
Why didn't they want to get rid of that double bond?
Cause that's the one that's going to give them the handle to get that ketone in
up there,
which is a very difficult position.
Okay,
so,
and then they could do sodium borohydride that made the alcohol that we showed
you before,
right?
But notice that the borough hydride didn't attack here.
It only attacked down here.
Okay.
Then they made the acetate from that alcohol and now they've got to convert this
to cortisone.
At this point in our synthetic work are our synthetic work intersects the lines
previously laid down in the extensive prior investigations by many groups.
So he goes through some of these groups,
hymen and Feeser,
that's the guy that wrote this story,
right.
Have recently converted the asset Toxi Esther three into this compound five.
So the reference to that,
it was work at 1951.
So what they did was to,
uh,
let's see.
Uh,
okay.
That's they,
well,
whoa,
Whoa,
whoa.
You're doing a lot of stuff here.
Okay.
Reaction for oh,
reference for reference five then referenced six,
puts that thing on up there and then a reference a seven puts the alcohol in or
whatever.
Uh,
and finally the double bond by Maddix and Kendall.
Well,
Kendall remembers the guy that got the Nobel prize,
the chemist at the Mayo Institute.
Okay.
So that did it.
They had it,
they'd solve the intellectual artistic problem of how you can start with simple
available compounds and make cortisone.
Right?
But what was the yield?
Think of better at about yield.
Okay.
Suppose you do 39 steps and each step has an 80% yield,
which isn't so bad as you've found in lab.
Right?
Okay.
Then the overall yield is 0.01% if you take 0.8 to the 39th power,
but there's a different way to go about it.
Like what's called a convergence synthesis,
where you make several big pieces and then link the pieces together.
So the distance in number of steps for many one starting material to the product
is smaller than having all 39 in a row,
right?
So you could start with something that does nine steps.
Say that makes a another nine steps sequence makes be another.
Make see it.
Another makes d and now you put a and B together and c and d together to make
enf and then you put them together.
And now the distance is only a nine steps plus two steps for any given starting
material and you get a 9% yield.
Right?
So convergence synthesis has real advantages.
Now,
how got a practical cortisone synthesis that could make something that people
could afford to use?
Well,
there's cortisone.
Remember that's what,
that's what the,
the Nobel laureate said,
there are two things you can do.
Either do a total synthesis or get a better starting material than it was then
available.
So choose a inappropriate,
readily available starting material.
Okay.
Does oxy Coley Casad a bile acid,
which you can get from slaughter houses or get the glands from which to make it
from slaughterhouses.
Okay.
It comes from ox bile.
So in 1946,
49 Merc made a kilogram of cortisone from 600 kilograms of that bile acid,
which came from an enormous about of stuff from the slaughterhouse.
But notice why that was a good starting material.
It has all the rings in place of the right size,
right properly and is properly methylated.
So it's got the skeleton,
the carbon skeleton,
it's got all those things in the right stereochemistry right?
It's got here,
uh,
functionality,
functional groups at or near at least some of the proper positions.
Right?
You're going to have to fiddle around out here somehow.
But
how are you going to do that?
Right.
Well,
you could imagine a go,
they were able to go in 12 steps to that and we're not going to go through what
those next 20 steps are that allow you to get the red thing.
But you can imagine,
you could imagine things like do a Broman nation at a tertiary position.
Maybe you could do that.
Uh,
then then may eliminate Hbr,
maybe could go the wrong way.
Then maybe you could cleave the double bond and make the ketone.
Then maybe you could do Alpha Broman nation to the adjacent to the ketone and
then make alcohols from that.
Something like that.
You can imagine that's not what was done.
That wouldn't be 20 steps,
right?
It didn't work that way.
But you can imagine ways that you could get at it.
So they did it in 20th steps.
Okay.
So then they got cortisone and they could sell it in 1949 for $200 a gram having
made it by 32 step sequence.
Okay.
But there's another style,
another compound called diaas genet and dialysis.
Jenine also has the right set of rings and the right stereochemistry and
functionality.
And in a good place,
right?
And it's abundant in a Mexican Yam.
And Russell Marker,
uh,
who was an organic chemist at Penn State University,
went exploring.
He sort of quit and went down to Mexico and looked around to see if he could
find natural things that gave that contained a lot of this and some the roots of
this Yam.
Some of them are,
you know,
uh,
our,
20 or 50 kilograms and a fair percentage of it is this stuff,
right?
So he,
he was able to find a good source of this,
right?
And it could be converted in five steps into progesterone,
a female hormone,
right?
And so in 1943,
he got 10 tons of that Yam and from it made three kilograms of progesterone,
which was then worth a quarter million dollars,
which is in,
in 1943,
which is like,
I dunno,
you know,
$5 million.
Now he had the world's supply of progesterone,
which is a pregnancy hormone.
And so it was selling in 1955 for 48 cents a gram,
right?
Instead of this $200 grabbed stuff.
Okay.
But there's a problem if you want to get cortisone in this way because there's
no foothold to get out that position rather than that one or that one or that
one or that one or that one or that one or that one.
Right.
How are you going to put the ketone in?
And this is where it was found actually by this guy here or by his research
group.
Uh,
Fredrick Heil,
who was an undergraduate and graduate student here was the director of research
at Upjohn and Upjohn
research in Kalamazoo.
They found out that they had some of this,
a mold started growing on a dish that was in a window sill.
And when you put it on here,
it put a ketone in that position.
Okay.
For me,
put,
put the alcohol in that position.
But then once you got the alcohol here and they are home free.
Right.
Okay.
Now,
so a Woodward had done the total synthesis of cortisone and he did a lot of
total synthesis,
like the strychnine synthesis here.
Uh,
I thank Professor Saunders who took these pictures.
He was still a graduate student at this time in 1954 when strict me was
synthesized a,
and no,
the interesting thing about Woodward,
he,
there was a real cult of personality is still is among older people because
young people don't know who he was anymore
because he was such an artist.
I mean,
designing these things,
this is an art,
but you have to really know a lot to see the art in it.
And he has no bell citation actually said for his outstanding achievements in
the art of organic synthesis.
I don't think there's ever been another Nobel citation that said art in it.
So he made a lot of these things here.
Here was strictly in a very challenging thing.
And so when they got done,
they drew it very carefully on the blackboard and the postdocs who had worked on
it.
Uh,
Alice was a faculty member from the University of Bristol in England.
Hunger was a German Danika and Shanker where we're from.
Switzerland and Cava was an American who,
uh,
went to be a professor at,
at,
uh,
Penn.
Right.
But you notice the,
uh,
in,
in when he got the note,
when Woodward got the Nobel Prize,
his colleagues wrote this in science magazine,
Woodward style is polished,
showing an insight and sense of proportion that afford,
afford him strong convictions and a well developed a dramatic sense.
So you can see how just,
you know,
the ways lighting is cigarette there.
It looks sort of a dramatic to me and look,
look at his signature.
He always signed minuscule signatures,
right?
There are be Woodward,
And they also put a check mark on it,
but they finished the synthesis and down in the bottom wrote fic coat.
So,
you know,
Latin that,
but that as I talked to victor bears in the classics department,
that's not a proper Latin word,
but fate chair,
it means they made it right?
So that's what they almost got it right of it that way.
But I did that on the blackboard.
But one of the hallmarks of,
of,
uh,
Woodward style was that he always wore the same color blue suit and blue tie.
So I,
so that's Woodward blue tie.
And in fact,
students,
uh,
students painted one Halloween,
painted his parking place that light blue.
And I know where they got the paint because I got it.
Okay.
So then in 1973,
they did this real pinnacle of,
of synthesis that synthesize vitamin B 12.
You can't imagine all the problems that were faced by this.
And it was a collaborative work between a Woodward and ash and Mosers laboratory
at,
at the Ata Hod and Zurich and Switzerland.
Right.
And in connection with this work is where Woodward discovered stereo chemical
control by orbital symmetry.
Those are called the Woodward Hoffman rules,
you know,
con rotation,
dis rotation.
And it was while working on this that he discovered that,
hey,
they had a hundred coworkers at these two labs working on this.
All of them very,
very talented,
including this Guy Yoshito Kishi who was a faculty member from cute from Nagoya
University who had come to work on this project with,
with uh,
with Woodward.
And this is what Woodward wrote about him went in pure and applied chemistry in
1971 he wrote about working on the beat 12th synthesis.
The first prep preparation of Cora generalized afforded striking testimony of
the experimental skill of its discovered,
Dr Yoshito Kishi,
all the operations had to be conducted with every conceivable precaution and
respect,
a purity of reagents,
exclusion of oxygen and moisture,
and with the greatest possible speed.
So he was a real wizard in the laboratory and he then joined the Harvard Faculty
after that and then succeeded.
Woodward is professor of Harvard after Woodward's untimely death,
and we've seen his name before,
not for this.
He ultimately synthesized Paly toxin,
this compound,
which has a see 123 h,
two or 13 eno,
53 right?
It's got 42 functional groups,
which were protected in eight different ways.
So you could remove some of them and put others on and so on.
Right?
It has 62 Steria agentic centers.
It has seven double bonds that could be either a or z.
So there tend to the 20th Stereo isomers problem possible.
Right.
And it was done convergently so they made eight different pieces,
right.
And then put those pieces together.
So you'd get no yield at all if you did this in a sequential synthesis.
Right.
But they actually made it right.
And it was not,
although that was just a tour de force,
it's related to practical stuff because we talked last fall about this asi a
drug which,
which has a lot of similarity to that.
Right.
And the week after we spoke about it in class,
the FDA approved it for treating metastatic breast cancer.
I remember we talked about whether that that was pending at the time.
And you'll notice that the leader of this group was Kishi the guy.
So he had cut his teeth on Paly toxin for synthesize and things like this so
that this drug can now be made synthetically,
practically and sold as a drug that way.
It's just incredible.
Okay.
So organic synthesis has come a long way from urea.
Remember what volar wrote to parts alias in 1828 that about the experiment on,
he reacted cyanic acid with ammonia and tried at crystal and substance appears,
which is an Ert baby.
Neither like signed eight nor like ammonia.
So that's the story.
But first that a little bit of thanks and credits,
uh,
first to George Maxfield who was my high school chemistry teacher.
Uh,
they,
uh,
I remember his doing,
he,
we,
we'd be working on something.
He wouldn't be doing anything at all.
And he'd go like this.
And the other thing he said he did was he said you'd make something,
you put it in a bottle and sell it to your neighbor.
So that's,
I'm quoting him
and there's a Theodore Roosevelt Williams who is my first college professor at
College of Wooster and then fees,
or we talked about,
and Bartlett and Conant was his boss who had two phd advisors,
a physical chemist,
Twu Richards who got the Nobel prize and organic chemist eep Kohler,
who was very,
these,
these three pictures were all taken at Yale.
That was when sterling was,
was dedicated.
This was at a meeting in 1931,
when Bartlet was just a 20,
uh,
24 years old.
Right.
And,
uh,
but Kohler never went to meetings.
He never left Harvard.
People would come there to talk to him,
but he wasn't interested in that.
He just taught all the time.
Right.
And he's Kohler's the one that made,
uh,
that finally resolved alley.
Remember we talked about Vantiff or that event off had predicted it,
but Kohler's the one that made it.
So Kohler was a student of Remsen who was at Johns Hopkins and Richard's studied
with Osvaldo.
Remember the guy that didn't believe in atoms?
And then the next generation back was fitting who,
who discovered the pinnacle reaction.
Right.
And the one person I couldn't find a picture of was Carl Schmitt,
who was,
who was at Riga in Latvia.
But he was described by Austin as the tall thin man with a small head and strong
nose,
ice,
gray hair and a thin beard and a very nice person.
Right.
And Schmidt had worked both with [inaudible] and volar.
He was first a student of volar who recommended him to leaving,
fitting had worked with volar.
So we're back to those guys and then to Galeo sack and but sales and then to
bear a bear to lay who was a colleague of Lavoie Oza.
And wrote how to name compounds.
But there there's some other heroes to whom we should pay homage,
even if they weren't our ancestors.
I,
you know,
this is right.
Who is this Emile Fisher,
the last lecture
Kerner,
the other guy who did a real proof in the 19th century,
James Clark Maxwell.
All right,
remember him?
Cooper,
right?
That,
that surveillance of carbon Lovaas Yay.
And Robert Hook,
there's no known picture of Hook,
right?
Because Newton probably destroyed it.
That's true.
Right?
But this,
this is a picture of somebody using hooks apparatus and Hook was a hunchback and
he drew that picture.
And I like to think that might be a self portrait,
although I certainly doubt it.
But Hook was certainly a great guy.
And then of course we have a lot of people,
you have to pay homage to it.
Yale too,
like a Sillivan with his tee shirt that says,
how do you know,
or a giant who's this hips,
right?
And on Zaga those two Gibbs was,
was uh,
are arguably the smartest guy in the 19th century,
are certainly among the top half dozen or so.
And own soccer was the same in this century.
Right.
And I actually had on soccer as a colleague,
we overlapped for a few years.
Okay.
I mean,
he's like fine month was in awe of on Zucker.
Right.
And when Ozarka got the Nobel prize,
when they called to inform him,
he asked what for?
Because he had done so many things that could have gotten the Nobel prize.
Okay.
And then,
you know,
this is,
yeah.
[inaudible] these are the colleagues I've enjoyed having around for awhile and
he came in and told people how he determined the heat of vaporization of carbon
and that would,
you know,
why Berg and here's professors,
Ziegler who gave,
these are people who gave lectures in the course.
Right.
And of course,
you know who's next,
not a faculty member,
but a graduate student from Yale.
All right.
And then someone who's almost from Yale,
Leslie's laser.
Oh,
Vich who spoke to you last semester.
He's from Israel,
but he comes so often to visit that,
well,
call him an honorary Yalie.
Okay.
And then,
uh,
the,
these people we quoted,
remember he's the guy that originated,
how do you know?
Hourly?
Right?
And she's the one that does it now.
And here,
this is my wife and that's John's wife.
And here's,
this was a night before last over across the street here at a meeting that
Connecticut,
Connecticut Science Teacher's Association,
uh,
when this plaque was awarded to my wife for,
and she's sitting back here
[inaudible]
and next to her is the biology professor from Boden who I've quoted and she's
saying back there too.
[inaudible]
and then these are the kids.
I mean,
this is the next generation,
right?
And they're here with Caroline Doty.
You know who Caroline and is a basketball player at Yukon.
Uh,
so we'd gone to the Yukon Gay,
so I don't know what they're going to do.
They might be a scientist,
they might be sadness.
It might be basketball players,
they might be lawyers,
doctors.
Right.
But you guys are going to be that too.
And you're going to be their teachers,
right?
Or they're healers,
or Lord Forbid,
defend them in court or something
like that.
Right.
Okay.
So there you are.
So I want to thank all of the students,
not only you guys,
but many years.
Okay.
So thanks.
We'll ever review on Monday and rule one 10 there's going to be a symposium
here.
So at class time on Monday,
we'll have a review down the hall and good luck on the final,
and that's it.
[inaudible].